c'est non non monsieur le procureur
général des proches de la république
française sa tâche et de requérir
[Musique]
ça va saigner
tu vas encore mal à parler de marche à
pied vers la marche pour aller jusqu'à
l'âge d'or bon indicatif
n'oubliez pas que l'accusé c'est lui je
regardais pas monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les jurés public
chéri comme il est étrange de l'homme
qui est devant nous aujourd'hui mesdames
et messieurs les jurés comme il est
mystérieux car en vérité je vous le dis
il y à un mystère jacques lanzmann qui
peut dire qu'il est l'homme véritable
qui se cachent sur noise mans il s'en
cache pas d'ailleurs de se cacher qui se
cache sous noise mans derrière cet
exhibitionniste provocateur et roublard
quelle est la vraie nature de ce penseur
goguenard et moustachu qui manie le
paradoxe jusqu'à prétendre qu'il aime
mieux son chien que ses enfants
car ne nous y trompons pas monsieur le
président quand l'accusé dit qu'il
préfère son chien à ses gosses c'est
pour le plaisir de choquer l'été dernier
au moment de partir en vacances
jacques lanzmann a balancé ses enfants
par la portière de la voiture à l'entrée
de l'autoroute du soleil afin que son
chien et lui-même ne soit pas refouler
des hôtels balnéaires où il aime à
cacher leur amour estivale et tout ça
tout ça pour ne pas faire comme tout le
monde pour se singulariser des honnêtes
français moyen qui charmante coutume
jettent leurs chiens pas leurs gosses
jettent leurs chiens en gerbes par delà
le bitume
dès les premiers beaux jours de l'été et
les chiots s'éventre gaiement aux
pierres des fossés où se fracasse tout
coup ange est multicolore contre les
panneaux routiers au ou courtes à perdre
haleine plaint d'un joli des espoirs
derrière l'auto du maître qui file en
chantant vers son beau pédalo ce qui
prouve que le chien est le meilleur ami
de l'homme avec la famille le pastis
bien sûr
et le foot j'ai oublié le alors je vous
le demande mesdames et messieurs les
jurés quelle est la vraie nature de
jacques lanzmann certes nous savons
qu'ils les journalistes qu'il est
écrivain qu'il a fait de la résistance
mais qui peut dire combien de fois il a
pris du café au lait ce matin voilà une
excellente question
je me remercie de me les poser car dieu
merci tous les hommes publics ne sont
pas aussi cachottier que vous monsieur
lansman j'ai rencontré l'autre jour
monsieur robert hersant chez des amis
bavarois que nous avons en commun francs
et bien lui
lui il a peut-être pas fait beaucoup de
résistance certes mais il reprend deux
fois du café au lait tous les matins et
s'en cache pas et des chalets lire
quelque chose qui me sied pas avec ma
position
alors s'il vous plaît monsieur lanzmann
je vous en prie un peu de simplicité
si haut qu'on soit assis ce n'est jamais
que sur son derrière disait toulouse
lautrec qui étaient toujours assis même
quand il était debout sur tout témoin
n'était pas du cul c'est pas de sa faute
ne l'oubliez jamais jacques lanzmann
pour être intellectuel on en est pas
moins homme
et si ça se trouve même jean luc godard
ou marguerite duras vont des fois au
cabinet même le président de la
république mais monsieur marché s est
pas parce qu on allait à fond ce type et
qu'on va pas au kevin et mais monsieur
le président rassurez vous ne vous
inquiétez pas je ne veux pas donner à
mon réquisitoire un ton scatologique
mais c'est humain et non pas ce serait
rabaissé le débat et on serait pas dans
la merde
il est temps pour nous maintenant de
demander la tête de demander une peine
pardon contre l'accusé de toute façon
que j'ai lendemain que je demande
toujours la tête je n'ai rien contre
vous personnellement c'est simplement
une charmante coutume à laquelle nous
tenons beaucoup ici j'ai peu de
principes mais j'y tiens en particulier
je demande toujours la tête de l'accusé
je vais toujours à la grand messe à ste
honoré d'eylau et dieu est quand même
plus propre dans le 16e et croyez moi je
ne rate jamais une messe et je ne rate
jamais une exécution capitale
la seule fois que j'ai raté une
exécution capitale c'est parce que ça
tombait au moment de la messe
donc mesdames et messieurs les jurés ont
fait comme d'habitude en lui coupe la
tête
je signalerai enfin à l'accusée à toutes
fins utiles que je vais chasser
prochainement avec le président de la
république
tagada j'adore et que je me ferai un
plaisir de demander votre grâce monsieur
lansman à condition que vous
recommenciez à écrire plus souvent des
chansons parce que ba na na nana na na y
en a ras
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
etonnant non
[Musique]